what is the nature of the meaning crisis
in modern times
what's its origin what's the explanation
well remember what i said
what i argued that the very processes
that make us adaptively intelligent
subject us to perennial problems of
self-deception self-destruction creating
[ __ ] for ourselves for other people
all of that and that can cause
you know
anxiety
existential anxiety it can cause despair
it can cause
a sense of absurdity
these are perennial problems
and across cultures and across
historical periods
human beings have come up with ecologies
of practices there's no one practice
there's no panacea practice they've come
up with ecologies of practices
for ameliorating that self-deception
and enhancing that fittedness that
connectedness that's at the core of
meaning in life
that's
prototypically what we call wisdom
and here's how i can show you one clear
instance of
the meeting crisis
is it's a wisdom famine i i can i i do
this regularly with my students
in the classroom i'll say where do you
go for information they hold up their
phone
where do you go for knowledge they're a
little bit slower and probably because
they're in my class they'll say well
science the university
i'll say where do you go for wisdom
there's a silence
wisdom isn't optional that's why it is
perennial cross-cultural
cross-historical because of the
perennial problems but we do not have
homes
for ecologies of practices that fit into
our scientific technological world view
so that they are considered legitimate
the fastest growing demographic group
are the nuns no nes's they have no
religious allegiance but they are not
primarily atheistic
they
most frequently describe themselves with
this very this is this has become almost
everybody now described i'm spiritual
but not religious
which means they are trying to find a
way of reducing the [ __ ] and
enhancing the connectedness but they
don't want to turn to any of the legacy
established religions by and large
well isn't is both religion and the nuns
isn't wisdom a process not a destination
so trying to find if you're a deeply
faithful
religious person you're also trying to
find
right so just because you have a
a place where you you're looking or a
set of traditions around which you're
constructing
the search it's nevertheless a search
and is isn't so i guess
is there a case to be made that this is
just the usual human condition
uh though how do you answer if you asked
five centuries ago where do you look for
wisdom i mean i suppose people would be
more inclined to answer while
the bible or
a religious text right and they had a
worldview
that was considered not just religious
but also rational
so we now have these two things
orthogonal or often oppositional
spirituality and rationality but if you
go before a particular historical period
you look back in the neoplatonic
tradition like before the the scientific
revolution those two are not in
opposition they are deeply interwoven
so that you can
have a sense of legitimacy and deep
realness and grounding
in your practices
we don't have that anymore and i'm not
advocating for religion neither am i an
enemy of religion i'll strengthen your
case by the way
so one of my ras did research and you
get people who are have committed
themselves to cultivating wisdom and you
can look at people within religious
traditions and people who are doing it
in a purely secular framework
by many of the measures we use to try to
to study
wisdom scientifically the people in the
religious
paths do better
than the secular but here's the
important point there's no significant
difference between the religious paths
so it's not like if you're you know
following the path of judaism you're
more likely to end up wiser than if you
follow buddhism
by the way i don't know if that's my
case i was making the case that you
don't need to have a religious
affiliation to search for wisdom it's
that i thought along
to the point you just made that it
doesn't matter which religious
affiliation or none but that's what i'm
saying
it okay so this is the tricky thing
we're in yeah it does matter if you're
in one but it doesn't matter sort of the
propositional creeds of that there's
something else at work there's a if
you'll allow me this there's a
functionality to religion that we lost
when we rejected all the propositional
dogma but there's a functionality there
that we don't know how to recreate yeah
what is that can you try to speak to
that what is that functionality what is
that why is that so useful
a bunch of stories a bunch of myths a
bunch of narratives
i don't think that are drenched in like
deep lessons about morality and all
those kinds of things what is the what's
the what's the functional thing there
that can't be replaced without a
religious text by non-religious text
this is for me the golden question so
thank you
um do you have an answer
yeah i i have i think i have a
significant answer i don't think it's
complete but i think it's important and
this is to step before
the cartesian revolution and
think about many different kinds of
knowing and this is now something that
is prominent within what's called 4e
cognitive science the kind of cognitive
science i practice and there's a lot of
converging evidence for okay these
different ways of knowing there's
propositional knowing this is what we
are most familiar with in fact it's
almost
it's almost has a tyrannical status
right first so this is knowing that
something is the case like that cats are
mammals and it's stored in semantic
memory and we have tests of coherence
and correspondence and conviction right
there's procedural knowing this is
knowing how to do something
this is
skills are not theories they're not
beliefs they're not true or false they
engage the world or they don't and they
are stored in a different kind of memory
procedural memory
semantic memory can be damaged without
any damage to procedural memory that's
why you know you have the prototypical
story of somebody suffering alzheimer's
and they're losing all kinds of facts
but they can still sit down and play the
piano flawlessly
same kind of argument
there is perspectival
knowing this is knowing what it's like
to be you here now in this situation in
this state of mind the whole field of
your salience landscaping what it's like
to be you here
now and you have a specific kind of
memory around that episodic memory and
you have a different sense you have a
different criterion of realness
so you can you can get this by well we
my friend dan chappie and i we studied
the scientists using moving the rovers
around or you can take a look at people
who are doing vr
people talk about you know
they want they want to really be in the
game that makes it real they don't mean
their similitude you can get that
right sense of being in the game with
something like tetris which has isn't
like it doesn't look like the real world
and you can fail to have it in a video
game
that is has a lot of verisimilitude it's
something else it's about again this
this kind of connectedness that we're
talking about if i may interrupt is that
connected to the heart problem of
consciousness the subject the qualia or
is it a different that kind of knowing
is that different from the quality of
consciousness i think it has to do with
well i make a distinction between the
adjectival and the adverbial qualia so i
think it has to do with the adverbial
qualia much more with the when than with
the adjectival so the adjectival qualia
are
like the greenness of green and the
blueness of balloon the adverbial qualia
are
the hereness
the now-ness that togetherness yeah
and i think the prospect of knowing has
a lot to do with the adverbial qualia
adjectival qualia and adverbial quality
i'm learning so many new things today
okay so
uh that's another way of knowing right
the perspective and then there's a
deeper one
and this is a philosophical point and i
don't want to
we can go through the argument right but
you don't have to know that you know in
order to know because if you start doing
that you get an infinite regress there
has to be kinds of knowing that doesn't
mean you know that you know that
yeah okay of course okay great okay good
well there was a lot of ink spilled over
that over a 40-year period so by
philosophers they spill this is what
they do this is the link yeah but i want
to pay for ink spillage so i want to
talk about
what i call participatory knowing this
is the idea that you
and the world
are co-participating in things and such
that real affordances exist between you
so
both me and this environment are shaped
by gravity so the affordance of walking
becomes available to me
both me and a lot of this environment
are shaped by my biology and so
affordances for that are here
look at this cup
shared physics
shared sort of biological factors look
at my hand i'm bipedal yeah also culture
is shaping me and shaping this i had to
learn how to use that and treat it as a
cup
so
this is an ancient arena relationship
right there's identities
in being created in your agency
identities being created in the world as
an arena so you and the world fit
together you know when that's missing
when you're really lonely or you're
homesick or you're suffering culture
shock so this this is participatory
knowing and it's the sense of it comes
with a sense of belonging
at every level
so
the ability to walk is a kind of
knowledge yes yes that the that there's
a dance between the physics that enables
yes this process and just
participating in the process is the act
of knowing right and there's a really
weird form of memory you have for this
kind of knowing it's called yourself
what
can you elaborate well if you you so
so we talked about how all the how all
the different other kinds of knowing had
specific kinds of memories semantic
memory for propositional procedural
right episodic for perspectival
what do you what's the kind of memory
that is the coordinated storehouse of
all of your agent arena relationships
all the roles you're going to take all
the identities you can assume all the
identities you can
what what's the self do you mean like
consciousness or like i see your sense
of self sense of self in this world
that's not consciousness that's uh
an agency or something right it's an
agent arena relationship and so in an
agent arena relationship it's the sense
of
the agent
and and and that the agent belongs in
that arena whatever the agent is
whatever the arena is because there's
probably a bunch of yes different
framings of how you experience that yeah
and you and you do you have all within
your identity as a self you have all
kinds of roles that are somehow
contributing to that identity but are
not equivalent to that identity
yeah
i wonder if like my two hands have
different
because there's a different experience
of me picking up something with my right
hand
and then my left hand
so are those like uh
that's a really cool question lex
they certainly feel like their own
things
and but that could be just uh
anthropomorphization based on cultural
narratives and so on
it could but i think it's a legitimate
empirical question because it also could
be sort of ian gilchrist stuff it could
be
you're using different hemispheres and
they sort of have different agent arena
relationships to the environment this is
a really important question in the
cognitive science of the self does the
does that hemispheric difference mean
you're multiple or you actually have a
singular self oh so it's important to
understand how many uh cells are there
yes i think so but that's that's just
like a quirk of evolutionism
it's not it surely can be fundamental to
cognition having multiple cells or a
singular self
it depends um again because
uh we're getting
far from the answer to the question you
you originally asked me do we want you
want me to go back to that first or
answer this which question i already
forgot everything what's the
functionality of religion yes that's
okay
okay and then we can return to the self
okay
so you said you know you have all these
propositions and et cetera et cetera and
they different from the religions and
they're not
they don't seem to be considered
legitimate by many people
but yet there's something functioning in
the religions that is transforming
people
and making them wiser and i put it to
you
that the transformations are largely
occurring at those non-propositional
levels
the procedural
the perspectival
and the participatory and those are the
ones by the way that are more
fundamentally connected to meaning
making because remember the propositions
are representational and they're
dependent on the non-propositional
non-representational processes of
connectedness and relevance realization
so religion goes down deep to the
non-propositional and works there that's
the functionality we need to grasp well
you talk about
tools essentially that humans are able
to incorporate into their cognition
psychotechnologies like language is one
i suppose
uh
isn't religion then
a psychotechnology it would be a yeah an
ecology of psychotechnologies yes and
the question is
that nietzsche ruined everything by
saying god is dead
uh do we have to invent the new thing
go to from the old phone create the
iphone invent the new psycho technology
that takes place of religion and so when
the madman in nietzsche's text goes into
the marketplace who's he talking to he's
not talking to the believers he's
talking to the atheists and he says do
you not realize what we have done
right we have taken a sponge and
wiped away the sky we are now forever
falling we are unchained from the sun we
have to become worthy of this yeah well
nietzsche is full of romantic [ __ ]
as well no no no but there's a point
there yes the point is
right there's one thing to rejecting the
proposition there's another project of
replacing the functionality that we lost
when we reject the religion so his worry
that as nihilism takes hold you don't
ever replace
the thing
that religion
uh
the role the religion played in our
maybe it's it's hard to tell what he
actually because he's so multi-vocal um
i i i'll speak for me rather than
fenichi i think it is possible
to
using the best cognitive science and
respectfully accepting what we can from
the best religion
and philosophy philosophical traditions
because there's things like stoicism
that are in the gray line between
philosophy and religion
buddhism is the same
doing that best cogsi that best
exactation we can come up with
that functionality without having to buy
into
the particular propositional sets of the
legacy religions that's my proposal i
call that the religion that's not a
religion
so things like stoicism or modern
stoicism those things
don't you think in some sense they
naturally
emerge
don't you think there's a longing for
meaning
so stoicism arises during the
hellenistic period
when there was a significant meaning
crisis in the ancient world because of
what had happened after the breakup of
alexander the great's empire so
if you if you compare aristotle to
people who are living after
alexander so aristotle grows up in a
place where
everybody speaks the same has a language
has the same religion his ancestors have
been there for years he knows everybody
after alexander the great's empire
broken is broken up people are now
thousands of miles away from the
government
they're surrounded by people because of
the dysphorias right the
diasporas i should say they're
surrounded by people that don't speak
their language don't share their
religion that's why you get all these
mother religions emerging right
universal muslim religions like isis etc
so there is a there is what's called
domicide there's the killing of home
there's a loss of a sense of home and
belonging and fittedness during the
hellenistic period and stoicism
arose specifically to address that and
because it was designed to address a
meaning crisis it is no coincidence that
it is coming back into prominence right
now
well there there could be a lot of other
variations and it feels like it feels
like
i think when you speak of the meaning
crisis you're in part describing
not prescribing you're describing
something that is happening but i would
venture to say that
if we just leave things be
the the meaning crisis dissipates
because we long
to create institutions to create
collective ideas so this distributed
cognition process that give us meaning
so if religion loses power we'll find
other institutions that are sources of
meaning
i don't is that is that is that your
intuition as well
i think we are already doing that i do i
am involved with
and do participant observation
of many of these emerging communities
that are creating ecologies of practice
that are specifically about trying to
address the meeting crisis i just
in late july i went to washington state
and did rafe kelly's evolve move play
return to the source
and wow
one of the most challenging things i've
ever done
that guy is awesome by the way i've
gotten to interact with him a long long
time ago uh he said he said to say hi to
you by the way yeah it's from another
world it feels like a different world
because i interacted with him not
directly but so he this is somebody
maybe you can speak to what he works on
but
he makes movement and play
he encourages people to make that a part
of their life like how how you move
about the world whether that's as part
of sort of athletic endeavors or actual
just like walking around around the city
yeah um
and i think the the reason i ran into
him is because there was a lot of
interest in that in the athletic world
in the in the grappling world in the
brazilian jiu jitsu world people who
study movement who make movement part of
their life to see
how how can we integrate play and fun
and
and uh just the the basic humanness
that's natural
to our movement how do we integrate that
into our daily practice so
so this is yet another way to find
meaning i think it's actually an example
of what i was talking about because
what's going on with rafe's integration
of parkour in nature right and
martial arts
um and mindfulness practices and
dialogical practices
is exactly and explicitly so by the way
he's he will tell you he's been very
influenced by my work he's trying to get
at the non-propositional kinds of
knowing that make meaning by evolving
our sensory motor loop and enhancing our
relevance realization because that gives
people profound improved sense of
connectedness to themselves to each
other and the world and
i'll tell you alex i won't i don't want
to say the
i don't want to say too specifically the
final thing that people did because it's
part of his secret sauce right
right but what i can say is when it was
done
i said to them all i said as far as i
can tell none of you are religious right
and they go yeah yeah but what you just
did was a religious act wasn't it and
they all went yeah
it was
you